they saw the end of the world I could
feel all this death Jean it was just a
dream in the forest you
I've been called many things over many
lifetime
tried
raaah krishna yahweh ever since the
world found out about mutants there have
been secret societies who see them as
some kind of second coming or sign of
God they believe the tens of thousands
of years ago ancient being was born the
world's first Newton you are all my
children and they lost
because you follow the
leaders but I am here now I'm here for
you wherever this being was he always
had 4 followers he would imbue with
power like the Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse got that one for the Bible
nor the Bible about it from him what is
it
Oh God he can control all of us
the world needs the x-men that's why I'm
here to fight
not all of us can control our powers
then don't this is war
everything they feel
will fall and from the ashes of their
world will build a better one
I've never felt power like this before
really it's childish we can imagine
tequila's leave an inkling agari